Speaker 1: We have some good but potentially
temporary news, depending on who the next
president is, and that news is that President
Joe Biden has suspended drilling leases in
the Arctic National Wildlife Refuge, also
known as ANWR.
The decision blocks for now oil and gas drilling
in one of the largest tracts of undeveloped
wilderness in the United States.
The Biden administration yesterday suspended
oil drilling leases in ANWR.
Unschooling, a signature achievement of the
Trump presidency.
That's a good thing.
And delivering on a promise by President Biden
to protect the fragile Alaskan tundra from
fossil fuel extraction.
The decision sets up a process that could
halt drilling in one of the largest tracts
of untouched wilderness in the US home to
migrating waterfowl Cariboo and polar bears.
But it also lives over as much as 11 billion
barrels of oil.
And Democrats and Republicans have fought
over whether to allow drilling there for more
than four decades.
A former formal order from Secretary Interior
Secretary Deb Halland paused the leases until
her agency has completed an environmental
analysis of their impact and a legal review
of the Trump administration's decision to
grant them.
So this is good.
This is this is what could be done right now.
We're four months in or but yeah, four months
and almost five, four and a half months into
Joe Biden's presidency.
But this really needs to be made permanent.
And the point that I keep going back to on
this is we really don't need this.
And, of course, you know, the right wingers,
the gas price will go up a tenth of a percent
again and they'll point to this.
I actually saw a comment on Reddit which said
nothing like importing foreign oil at increased
rates just so that later we can go and drill
the very oil that we are now protecting.
No one is thinking long term.
That is such an incorrect perspective.
The whole point here is we should be moving
away from oil.
Anybody who's saying, you know, the goal for
energy should be let's keep pushing, even
if it takes years to be drilling in the Arctic
and the ANWR refuge.
No, no, no, no, no.
We we should be using this time during which
we actually already have plenty of oil to
transition away from oil.
And I think that very often this debate gets
into these strawman arguments like, listen,
if you shut off oil today, heat, indoor heating
goes away.
We don't have gasoline for vehicles.
We don't have this.
We don't have that.
I don't know who they're referring to when
they say that.
But I've never met anyone serious on the left
who says we should be off oil today.
I understand that if we there would be no
way to get off of oil today.
But the whole point here is we should be dramatically
accelerating solar power development.
Oh, but, David, there's not you can't use
solar power to generate.
Well, look at the efficiency increase we've
seen in solar panels over the last 20 years.
And if we get even half of the same over the
next 10, that goes a huge way in combination
with wind and geothermal, etc..
Now, there is a real conversation to have
about nuclear.
I've said before, new nuclear power is very,
very safe.
I am not a reflexive anti-nuclear activist
very often.
And we've talked to nuclear engineers on the
nuclear energy engineers on the show.
Very often there's this reflexive oh, but
look at look at Chernobyl and look at this
stuff from from the 70s.
The reality is that if we were to bring on
new nuclear today with modern nuclear technology,
none of those things would be issues.
So for me, I'm totally comfortable using new
nuclear as a stop gap.
What are the concerns that I have with it?
Number one, the disposal of the waste continues
to be an issue I don't know about, you know,
but there's people who say now you just ship
it, you put it underground is fine.
I'm just not sure about that.
I'm not saying there isn't a solution, but
that still remains a question for me.
But really, the bigger question for me with
saying let's use nuclear as a way to be a
bridge off of fossil fuels and onto real renewables,
is that it seems to me we would get addicted
to nuclear and it takes a while to bring new
nuclear technology online.
So my concern would be if we say let's do
new nuclear and it'll take eight years to
bring some of this online, by the time that
it's online, the fact that we've been focusing
on nuclear might have diverted energy and
attention and funding from get from real renewables.
And that scares me.
But in theory, I am not against doing a new
safe nuclear as a stopgap.
One other thing, there are people who like
to say the sun's not really renewable, you
know, I mean, we've got five to six billion
years of solar, OK, that's if we buy if the
human race survives that long, we can never
be certain about anything.
But I would be reasonably sure that we would
have moved somewhere where the sun exploding
in five to six billion years is not going
to be what destroys the human race.
So for all practical purposes, when we're
talking about peak oil and we're talking about
10, 20, 50, 100 year timelines of what we're
doing to the planet with oil use, five to
six billion years of solar power sounds pretty
damn renewable to me.
All right.
So good decision by Joe Biden will follow
it.
And of course, there's a bigger conversation
here about a bigger transition that needs
to take plac